good afternoon everybody welcome to mid
suffix cabinet meeting apologies for
absence number thieved declarations of
interest by counselors do counselors
need to indicate if there is a Silva was
just asking for clarification on whether
the SIL beads in the SIL paper if it's
in somebody's water do they need to
declare an interest
item three MTA 1951 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 10th
of February do I have a proposal
happy to ii against with god and does
anybody have any comments or as to the
accuracy of the minutes
while you're happy for me to sign them
please indicate thank you
I'm sorry I've jumped a couple item for
to receive notification of petitions in
the courts for the council's petition
scheme no received item five questions
by councillors nobody saved item six
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or the joint order and
standards committee there were none and
the forthcoming decisions list is
attached so item 8 MCA / 19 / 52 is the
general fund financial monitoring for
2019-20
a quarter 3 canceled waited thank you
madam chairman I'm pleased to introduce
report MC a 1952 on the general fund
monitoring which extrapolates the
lightly out term for this financial year
based on our actual financial
performance through the first nine
months of the year in this report I set
out in paragraph five point six we have
not repeated in detail matters that have
arisen in previous quarters these are
just notated as as reported at Q 2 so
that we will focus on variances that
have come to light over quarter 3 rather
than retrace overall ground now
excluding business rates which we dealt
with separately the net favorable
variance anticipated is 879 thousand
pounds the biggest drivers of this
positive variance are additional
planning in Cometh order of 60,000 and
the administrative income 5% slice
arising from the community
infrastructure levy receipts of 320,000
pounds despite our best efforts we more
bullish in forecasting planning income
each year it continues to exceed our
original expectations we have assured to
track record of the receipts on SIL
where they to have surpassed on the
upside having said that it does raise in
my mind what effect the coronavirus
might have on our 2021 income in these
areas if economic activity takes a sort
of knock that the crashing stock market
is suggesting
such out-of-the-blue events refer to an
investing parlance as Black Swan events
reinforce it in my mind they need to
have strong reserves as a fallback our
speculation about the future effects of
the coronavirus on our council finances
can be merely speculation at this time
however the world's robust response to
this outbreak was surely fit the Oxford
English dictionary's definition of
emergency subject 23rd of various arise
in q4 the intention would be to transfer
this eight hundred and seventeen
thousand positive variants to our growth
and efficiency fund before moving on to
other matters I must also point out the
hit to income a four to six thousand
from problems arising with our part car
parking machines over the last summer my
seat has already become the headline
feature of this report in the East
Anglian newspaper the old machines are
being replaced and other machines
upgraded to ensure this issue doesn't
arise again business rates for a variety
of reasons set out in the report in
paragraph 5.9 showing adverse bearers of
three hundred and thirty two thousand
and this various secret twenty further
changes will be set against the business
rakes equation reserve at the year-end
the report also sets out news of our
efficiency fund another remark reserves
cattle expenditure reporting starts from
paragraph five sixteen and the report
sets out some of the difficulties in
forecasting the timing of capital
spending the reasons are valid but I do
think collectively that timing floor
cast improvements can be made going
forward by actual value a lot of the
carry forwards relate to zip code might
take comfort here in observing that we
are ensuring that any investment fits
our strict criteria although we are not
rushing to invest outside our strict
guidelines at this point prior to the
year-end
and establishing the final out term for
the year if variances are all just for
noting hence the three recommendations
set out in paragraph three or lend in
the words be noted I'm pleased to move
these recommendations and we have
transfer questions arising from this
report but first ask for someone to
second these recommendations
okay
happy two-second madam chairman do we
have any questions
councillor whitehead or our officers
just cancel the Fleming Thank You leader
um I just have a question on paragraph
five point four which is the general
fund revenue account in relation to the
collection rate it seems that it's quite
high and I would just like to know what
we're doing to try and make that some a
bit better the collection rate is not
far off last year's performance eight
point eighty five point three six
against a five point seven nine what we
are experiencing some difficulty in
collecting the cows the tax reduction
amounts that are under the local council
tax reduction scheme but also at the
same time more people seem to moving
from ten month direct debits to 12
months direct debits and that to has an
effect because the cash flow is spread
out more but as far as we're concerned
in that's one piece concern I think um
we've got no reasons to be concerned at
the moment in terms of council tax
equation thank you go just not having
the perspective of years to understand
whether this is good bad or indifferent
I still think that almost 15% of
uncollectible presumably most of that is
written off he's an awful lot it's
almost a million pounds and I really
would like us to see some serious focus
on improving that number no situation is
as at the end of December nine months
into the year we've collected
eighty-five percent of the council tax
in a period of time which relates
75% of the council taxi and so that
point of view we're actually ahead of
where we might be if you like the purely
from a chronological point of view are
there any more questions from cabinet
members councillor Brewster and thank
you madam chairman yes although perhaps
technically not in here but it is
mentioned and new homes bonus we've
heard a lot of talk about nine million
in the new homes bonus was reading some
figures up the other day which which
suggests that the unallocated some of
the new homes bonus is just nearing the
three million mark just wonder if the
council sorry the cabinet men provide
for finance can assure me that that
unallocated sum is the actual sum that
is there to spend if we need to I think
I got the gist of the situation it so
far as yeah we've got a brought forward
figure of nine million I was shown an
allocated at remaining of three million
they're actually the any of the years
out term which was saying is 879 would
be added to that so it's somewhere
perhaps approaching at the four million
mark but it's important when we look at
that that we do realize that there are
projects in there already allocated a
strategic investment fund the Regal
theater which subsidy is happening over
this summer and the ongoing project the
battery storage which I believe is going
to involve into a bigger project anyway
potentially and I mean the main thing is
that this growth and efficiency fund
it's there for special or not so for
example refurbishing for example leisure
centers we can do that almost tees if we
have a fund like this rather than trying
to work out where it would come from day
to day expenditure
yes I'm a further question and more or
less a comment on paragraph 519 which is
the disabled facilities grant situation
just to say to request clarity on window
7 and a half thousand pounds grant will
be formally approved I had somehow I
thought it had been but reading this
paper it looks as if that maybe that's a
typo in the paragraph is it sir perhaps
we could have some comment on that and
then also on where we're going with
trying to spend more of the available
grant to try our best to make the way
that grant is used and can be used as
flexible as possible and as you know
Leafs bureaucratic as possible where
what are we doing to work with the
County Council and the provider if that
is to be orbit I'm trying to facilitate
this was awarded the this report
obviously comes in draft to the capital
of pre things said mostly it's been
written properly for the last month so
there is a sort of overlap here between
when the report was first written and
subsequent developments in terms of the
disabled Sea Grant changes so my
understanding is that moved beyond 5,000
pounds of it has already been agreed in
terms of how this it's going to be spent
going forward that's not racial Matt
which I look at me to look to other
people to help me
thank you Joe um just to confirm yes
that the 7000 is in place and has been
since members approved the regulatory
reform order policy that Baber and mid
Suffolk are the first councils in
Suffolk to have adopted such a scheme I
can reassure members that as chair the
Suffolk Housing Board all Suffolk
authorities are currently looking at the
way that DFG administered bearing in
mind that we are in the last year of a
current contract with orbit by HIA 4
which has been running for for five
years and I would expect to bring papers
back to members probably in July with an
explanation as to how we're going to
deliver d fgs beyond the the current
contract and there are lots of
negotiations and discussions going on as
to how best to deliver that to
ultimately ensure that the budget
available to us gets spent and therefore
gives people with a disability the
adaptations that that you require cancer
even
thank you very much - chair I've got a
couple of questions if I may
but firstly to help councillor Brewster
there's a you've also got the strategic
investment fund of three million to
spend some point during the year but my
questions are on the five point six and
five point seven B I just wondered if
the cabinet member for finance could
just say whether the underspend is
likely to influence what's being a set
in the budget for 2021 and secondly you
know the carpark income which is the
story of the day it's interesting that
that loss is actually less than we
proposed to spend in our budget
amendments for council and I'm concerned
about reports of some conservative
councillors talking about doing down to
do market whereas what we're trying to
do is look at see how they can be
investment in stone markets so I was
just wondering whether it's possible
chair to have any further discussion
with you about the use of car parking
income in stone mark in how that can
work out and also just to get the
confirmation that that that we're sure
because I've heard of issues at the
meadow Center as well that we're sure
that those circumstances have been
resolved let's say for for that for that
so I appreciate it was answer on that
thank you very much did you want to
reply on the first point I didn't
actually quite understand the first
point insert as far as when you talked
about five point six were you asking
whether those Faris's have been taken
into account for next year's picture
yes if the because it's quite a high
underspend it's whether that's going to
influence you know whether having to set
the budget there's going to be some
you're going to think actually one might
make some changes to it because we've
got additional funding that we weren't
expecting that's the question really
well I think I think when I I think we
in my introduction I tried to sort of
address adding in so far as saying
despite our best efforts to be more
bullish in forecasting planning income
and sill income just continue to exceed
our expectations but then I did flag the
the concern that looking forward trying
to crystal ball gaze yeah who knows what
might become coming down the line with
the coronavirus so it's all asking me
how long is a piece of string which you
know hasn't been in ruffled yep on your
point on the copper the these are we've
already been discussing these as part of
the CPE initiatives that we're going on
if you want to feed into officers your
thoughts then we'll make sure they're
taken into account
[Applause]
Thank You chair um I've got some
questions on Appendix C which I don't
quite understand I wonder if I could
have some help this is headed the growth
and efficiency fund which I assume is
just a mid supper fund and so we've got
figures in the budget if I look at
capital investment strategy for instance
do we have a budget or is it a shared
budget with with Bebo 136,000 and then
when we do all the other Suns across
there that is the variance a mid suffer
variance or is it a shared variance
then when we come on to item four on
that list we've got the town visually
and engagement project where it says mid
Suffolk 90% baby 10% and yet it it looks
as if it's it's more it's closer to 2018
not 1090 and the third question is a
query about the shop front and access
improvement grants we we manage our
budget of 350,000 we managed to spend
seven thousand in the first year just
less than that almost 12,000 in the
second year and we've still got three
hundred and thirty one thousand to spend
are we going to do it are we going to
spend it you know what is the likelihood
that that grant is going to be taken up
in full the appendix E is headed up
growth efficiency funding now the the
paper equivalent is still referred to as
the transformation fund but most of
those are joint projects particularly
the ones you'll see where it says
commutators spend which shows two
headings Bebo and it's mr. [ __ ] and
therefore those will have varus's that
are split mainly 50/50 between the ones
they the other ones where the final
right-hand columns wish of commitments
in green and brown show the amounts
still to be spent and how that's being
split between Weber and mr. Furth there
are quite a lot of projects arey each
unique project has its own are the
allocation to either bay the mississippi
call or both to your third points on to
come back to you on a second question to
two third point in terms the shop front
grants as you say they spend today seven
thousand then twelve thousand
is a drop in the ocean over the up hole
between and 50,000 grant but my
understanding is that those grants are
out there they've been publicized and
it's up to individuals businesses to
make applications to spend those on the
face of it looking at it pure
accountancy point of view it was seen
that it's going to take a long time to
spend but again there's an operational
thing I think someone else probably give
more background to it councillor
Brewster would you like to come in thank
you madam chairman and yes sometimes you
can take a horse to water and often you
can't make a drink but and this is to a
degree been being the case I mean all
the shots and still mark would have
certainly been circulated two or three
times I believe and certainly I've been
around myself there are areas which
which are not within the remit of the
that finance
however we are currently reviewing all
these grant schemes and the shop run
scheme is certainly one of those and
it's looking to a way to perhaps do
other things not other things with it
not that all in in the retail area and
in some of the business area and perhaps
a little bit wider than that and we'll
see how that one goes I'm pretty
convinced that once we've got that
reviewed on that money will start to be
spent so I did sorry could I just ask
counsel well him to repeat the second
question because I was distracted trying
to find the information for the first
question when when you when you made
your second question yes certainly if
you've got page 26 line four is the town
visioning an engagement project which is
split 10% night
and and yet when I look in there in the
gray columns Weber has spent ten and a
half thousand mid Suffolk have spent
nearly 41,000 that's not in the ratio of
10% 90% is there a reason for that will
it will it come out in the end at the
end of the day there's 10% 90% or are
there specific projects that this money
is being spent on so it will be the cost
so how much he spent will be the cost of
those separate projects rather than a
nine to one split I think unless
finalists can come to my immediate
rescue they'd be sensible to look into
that and give you a proper written
response afterwards but I'm open for
Finance tell if I go wrong i I think we
counselors need to look at the end
column so the the green and brown
columns is referred to already but as
the Whitehead and the commitments and
you'll see there that that my
rough-and-ready maths is that that's 10%
90% so effectively all the money spent
to date yes you could say a greater
proportion of Barbara's money has been
spent compared to a smaller proportion
of mid suffix but ultimately it'll come
out of that 10% 90% based on those
commitment figures on the far right
column so it is going to be at the end
of the day it's gonna be split 90/10
rather than what's been spent in which
in each particular district no matter
what the projects are well I would say I
put the word ish I guess H on the end of
that because obviously don't just spend
money for the sake of do the based on
what's needed but it's gonna be very
roughly 1090 split
so this money was for the five town
visioning work and that was set up
before I came think Elly 2019
it doesn't include some of Baber because
some of that work had already happened
so it's largely it was for the workshop
it was for an organization called
thinking place who came in and did
workshop events both in I need him and
stay market and also Hadley and that's
not what all the money was spent on it
wasn't all spent on consultants but
that's what part of the the funding was
spent on which white might explain the
split did you question I did just a
couple if I can return to page eighteen
for a minute just just a question again
about the the planning fee income and
the ceiling come clearly the objects to
get our estimates right as well as
surprised of the comment that says it's
unlikely to be repeated next year one
could understand planning three compacts
the mad rush to get things done before
the local plans finish my daughter why
but sill income must be related to
things are already under under why now
and second or third payment so you know
just any interest that we don't want to
underestimate that income I was
wondering what I'm failing to understand
there yeah but not just to concentrate
on the good things perhaps you look at
five nine it talks about business rights
and 337 kya this due to collection fund
deficit which was not known at the time
of setting the budget to someone
surprise that's a pretty chunky sum of
money so we deficit which is unknown
when you're setting a budget so is there
some good reason there and have we
tighten any action to make sure it
doesn't happen again that's all I did
but well in terms of SIL I wasn't saying
is going Thailand dry of it I was just
saying I was just thinking of a sort of
worst-case scenario if everybody's sort
of self-imposed what's the word you know
with this coronavirus and he was going
out looking to buy property and
reserving property and obviously
builders and developers developing
phases and if things slow down then the
phasing will slow down
how about drastically or small amounts
of you know changes but um yeah I was
just thinking a worst-case scenario
people just myself and stuck in the
doors then no no no moving house and
buying houses then that's a Lincoln
could potentially that's where I was
coming from anyway and I say that's
probably less than you know planning
planning matters which are um perhaps a
bit more spontaneous than long-term
developments in terms of the collection
fund deficit and the way this works
usually I rely on Kathryn Lazar our
expert there because of the way it works
I don't know yeah yeah standing are you
on this thank you yeah if I can just
help add some clarity to that and so
what we do is we have to submit returned
to the government called an energy r1
and we have to do that on the 31st of
January so that's too late in time for
us to set the budget and it looks back
to what we achieved in terms of
collection rates in terms of bad debt
provision on our collection fund for
business rates but if you remember we've
set aside the business rates the
equalization reserve because we don't
know each year whether it's going to be
a surface or a deficit so we've been
prudent in setting aside if we do have a
surplus that money in the reserve to
mitigate that fluctuation so there's
nothing we can do about the timing of
that but we're being prudent in setting
aside the reserve to mitigate that going
forward sort of still a bit difficult to
see you know you know what the business
is all you know what the gross rate is
it was just a little difficult to
understand why there's a 337 gram
difference the economy has been running
slowly but to you I don't know that
we've lost any major shopping centers or
anything in him it's a fairly robust
have been difficult to see why they we
didn't foresee it coming yeah it's not
so much around the businesses the the
other element you have to bear in mind
is the appeals that can come in at any
time as well and be backdated so we have
no control over when those are going to
hit us so that's that's the other
unknown factor that can can have a big
impact now I'm just gonna make a point
about the appeals but I'm happy that
this is done that okay so we've got a
seconder all in favor
thank you that's carried so moving on to
agenda item 9 is mca 19 slash 53 the
housing revenue account financial
monitoring 20 19 to 20 quarter 3
councillor why did thank you again i'm
joe and pleased now to give just a brief
introduction to the housing revenue
account quarter three financial
monitoring report again as with the
general fund it's based on the actual
nine months numbers then extrapolated to
the year-end
the year-end adverse varistor 218
thousands anticipated the biggest driver
behind this adverse varus is a
responsive repair and maintenance
undertaken using subcontractors to
ensure the work is undertaken in their
timely fashion and to an adequate
standard total various in that area was
actually two hundred seventy eight
thousand but it is offset by a reduced
revenue contribution to capital arising
from slippage ease in our capital
program it would be remiss of me not to
point out that the repair and
maintenance item is a real cost whereas
a positive variance is just a timing
issue
we'll reverse next year and the net
overspend will be offset against brought
forward reserves and the capital side
there has been a significant slippage on
the build program we are now
anticipating a capital carry forward on
new build and acquisitions for seven
point seven six three million as with
the general fund the variance of the
stage prior to year end are just four
noting and the recommendation is a
paragraph three are worded accordingly
so without more ado I'd like to move the
recommendations have out in paragraph
three but that's the cabinet member for
Finance Council firemen issued kind of
second these recommendations and
collectively for the housing ad and
finances present we'd be happy to answer
any questions arising on the report
Thank You chair happy to second the
record do we have any questions
cancelled Willem Thank You chair I just
note that the void that they've been
slightly higher Boyd's and anticipating
we had at render when Detroit eyes were
going down have we started to go up
again or is this just I mean it could be
just a couple of properties are just
some some reassurance we haven't started
to have a problem again please
thank you Jeff um I haven't got the
numbers in front of me I have to go away
and and just stick those out what I
can't confirm is it's a higher number of
voids it's not an increase in the number
of void days because that is still on a
downward trajectory so he guess it's
more a case that we are having more
voids than we would for coughed or
expect cancer either
thank you very much chair this is with
regards to paragraph 5.10 please the new
building that positions program I'm
pleased that that program still you know
continuing and and it's it is picking up
albeit with their carry forward but I'm
hopeful as with everybody here that
expect that we'll get some new builds
out to next year but one of my question
is that I understand we don't have a
local housing policy that we can apply
and so that where any new builds they're
built for affordable x' or soar social
rent just go to their mid suffered wide
Housing Register and can't be allocated
to local needs and particularly where
there's neighborhood plans being set up
which regi specifying local need and
also where builded where developers are
liaising a lot more parish councils
about what their local need is and
actually trying to to put housing on
their developments that meets that and
local need and I would just like some
assurance that that policy is being
looked at because I just feel if we're
doing this new bills program we really
need to do it in a aligned with a
written policy on local needs so that
those people living that area know it's
going to be for them thank you very much
chair councillor plantman
Thank You Jay yes we're definitely
looking at that and if you have a local
need or the land belongs to a local and
they put in the 106 that that that is
for local need that will happen so it
depends who owns the land but also we
are looking at the housing but you have
to you have to be able to prove that
that person does have a local need and
then if there isn't a local need then it
goes into the wider Suffolk area say
look looking at you know when roughly
that might come subdued you come here
wouldn't do it like your policy do you
know and roughly that might happen
so one of the corporate outputs is to
review the way that we let properties in
a review of our position using gateway
to home choice in the sub-regional
allocations policy we are scoping out a
project to review that members would
understand that that is quite a
significant piece of work and we're
currently working with Julia and and
other portfolio holders to understand
what the brief is and therefore focus on
what that would be as a project I would
expect to bring the results back of that
project within 12 months but that is a
full-scale review of of of choice-based
lettings encompassing the the relevant
policies as well
councillor Fleming thank you thank you
leader and another question about the
the deficit in relation to repairs and
maintenance the adverse variances
278,000 which is on pages 35 and 36 it
seems that it's bit more than
anticipated and it is quite a lot and
what are we doing to try to get that in
control do we have a maintenance problem
who's doing the work do we have a
problem with our contractor or
subcontractor if you could just give us
some clarity on them - yes we obviously
have had trouble with BMS and that's why
we are looking at looking at going into
business with a chosen partner obviously
we are still looking at that at the
moment and working through whether a
joint and partnership would benefit both
parties so at the moment we are just
looking at that and going through the
the business plan and the business plan
it might not be that we decide to go
with them but then again it might decide
that they might decide they don't want
to go with us so actually we're working
through that
and Gavin correct me if I'm wrong I'll
be looking to know this by the end of
May or June mainly so you'll get you'll
come back to us with options thank you
I respect members have raised the
additional adverse parents in relation
to building services we've talked about
building services for many many months
years in fact in terms of delivery of
that service which initiated in in
2017-18 with the decision to have an
in-house workforce delivering that
service I think it's important to note
that the overall cost of that service is
a net cost of delivering repairs and
maintenance and we're talking about an
adverse variance against budget of
278,000 for the year 1920 bond
reflection I just went back and looked
at the previous first two years of that
initiative and the delivery of building
services so at the end of two 17:18
adverse variance against budget of
900,000 pounds 1819 adverse variance of
672 against budget this year adverse
variance of 278 I used those figures
because I think it gives you a really
good story as to the direction of travel
in the delivery of building services in
that yes there is an adverse variance
this year but when you compare it
year-on-year and you have that that that
story actually we are becoming more and
more efficient in the delivery of
building services year-on-year so that
that's a reduction in adverse variance
of two-thirds over over the last three
years just whilst I've got the floor in
terms of reducing our demand on
subcontractors some of the things that
we are currently doing to reduce that
cost we're currently reading two
carpenters one labor and two apprentices
we're looking at contracts where we're
using subcontractors to deliver work eg
repairs to
fences we're looking at
Baxter - in an attempt to capitalize
some of that work we're reducing our
demand on contractors to deliver voids
because we're now far more efficient in
the delivery of void management we're
identifying opportunities to train
existing staff to carry out specialist
works where traditionally we've used
contractors to provide you PVC repairs
to doors and windows as an example and
we've recently revised the the team
structure giving more focus to the
management and supervision of
subcontractors where we need to use them
Richardson
thank you very much chair that was some
very useful context about the previous
history of the adverse standards for
repairs and maintenance can I just ask
off the back of that either to the
cabinet member or to the assistant
director for housing of how confident
are you that that trend will continue in
the next financial year so that we would
potentially see that variance either
significantly reduced or eliminated in
total so I can talk to you about the
direction of travel and I've talked to
you about some examples just in relation
to subcontractors we're actually seeing
significant improvements in delivery of
that service partly if I'm honest out of
working alongside flagship in the
development of the joint venture
business case so this year we've seen a
reduction in our cost of materials
through Travis Perkins that amounts to
about 60,000 pounds this year we've had
an ongoing problem since the inception
of building services that we have a
number of outstanding job tickets
outstanding job tickets means that work
has been raised but hasn't been either
completed or the cost of that haven't
been recovered in the last two months
that outstanding job list has reduced by
over 2000 job tickets so they're just
some of the examples that I'd allude to
as I bring a joint venture business case
back to members in due course then I
will also be briefing members on some of
the work that we've been doing and
undertaking in that
this over the last year because it's all
credit to the staff working in that
service that they are making the
improvements that both I and and and
members have desired for some time so I
have a proposal and a seconder
all in favor of recommendations 3.1 3.2
3.3 to be noted he's indicated
item 11 is MTA 1950 item 10 mca 1954
quarter three performance outcome
reporting and the report is actually in
the table papers so cabinet members you
have before you the performance report
and appendices for quarter three for the
current year the report recommends that
the information contained within and the
appendices be agreed as reflecting the
council's performance the report
provides you with a summary of the
performance highlights during quarter
three and identifies areas where
performance improvement is required the
appendices should be read alongside the
report as they tell the full story
providing detailed information on the
individual measures as well as
summarizing key achievements that give
an overview of the impact our
performance has on our communities
please note that the performance
information is only reported to you if
it is collectible in quarter three this
is most notable when the human within
the communities area where much of the
performance measure data is it collected
on a half yearly or annual basis and
will report it be reported next at the
end of quarter four work is underway to
review performance measures for
communities to align with a community's
strategy I would just like to thank you
all for the continued hard work and
support you have undertaken in
conjunction with your assistant
directors in reviewing and updating the
measures to ensure that the information
captured is relevant to the council's
priorities and I would like to call for
a second cancel which I'm happy to set
up a chair Thank You counsel
do we have any questions
yes guarding um it seems to be under
public protection but I think it
actually is environment on page that
isn't a page number actually aren't you
oh sorry there is on page 86 and 87 I
just have a question on two questions
actually one is on fly tipping I realize
this is my own portfolio so suppose I'm
asking myself the question perhaps ooh
officers could help me with this and
under its about fly tipping first how
how are we measuring performance
properly in terms of the trend the
downward trend is that a good thing or
is does it mean that fly tipping is just
not being reported can we have some
clarity on what our sort of performance
indicator is really telling us about
that and that's my first question did
you understand the question I mean is it
a good thing to have fewer reports it's
basically the class approach you can
help
shouts if that's okay oh yes it just to
confirm the reports of fly-tipping
are those from members of the public so
they are reports made to us I can't
comment on whether we're seeing a
decline in the reporting rather than the
instances of fly-tipping that's that's
something I think that the Assistant
Director for environment would probably
have some anecdotal information on
unfortunately she couldn't be here this
afternoon but as far as I'm aware those
are reports that are being made by
customers and members of the public and
I'm not so sure that we have any
anecdotal information to suggest that
people aren't reporting fly-tipping
thank you because some by observations
would look as if light a thing is
getting worse if you look around the
county but mmm maybe we can talk about
that it's a separate date
my other question relates really to the
next row which is about solar cap panels
and the fact that solar panels need
maintenance and get dirty Oh are we in
fact allocating enough resource to make
sure that the solar panels were
responsible for a cleaned and maintained
are we making the right assumptions here
thank you
um just in relation to to my work with
soda PV I think I can answer that
question I think it's fair to say that
when we introduced the idea of solar
panels and the installation offset
panels we didn't necessarily consider
the level of investment in maintaining
such sites what we have built into the
budget now is regular cleaning as well
as obviously repairing systems
and when they fail members will be aware
that obviously we've had problems in
relation to repair where we've had
inverters braking and the need to
replace those at a cost which would
never have been built into the business
case because the assumption was that
these components would last longer in
terms of their life cycle than they
actually are but I can reassure members
that there is a schedule of cleaning
every five years the panels that we we
do have some of those may need cleaning
more often if they're in particular
locations but that is in hand thank you
can I suggest that we actually consider
whether it's appropriate to develop a
target for maintaining the panels so
that we can understand how much it's
costing and and how how the panels are
performing in relation to their expected
lifespan
yes we do have that information and and
I am hoping to bring a report to
administration shortly on the delivery
of solar panels both in terms of the fit
gained as well as the energy generated
thank you I do have a couple more
comments on my own paper I'm afraid that
if you want me to as our assistant
director isn't here I can address them
separately and bring back I think it's
probably better if you address them to
the officer outside this meeting does
anybody else a counselor field thank you
however the questions are first a
comment and microphones are clearly set
out so they are howling on occasion
again and I've had to tell the county
about that I think you really will make
sure this at out properly you can tell
from the way you've always said carries
that
the gangs - I the questions I have are
that if you look at the human resources
at page 45 we have an issue of days lost
due to sickness which seems to be
getting a slightly well getting better
over the last year or so 18 months or
whatever and they suddenly spiked up
again and it says spiking the third
quarter is normal that it wasn't normal
in 1819 it did occur in 1718 somewhat
quite clear why it's normal perhaps one
does get more sick in the winter but
probably caught before and the more
worrying thing perhaps is a long term
sickness issue in the next titled down
which again was got steadily worse
through 1617 spiked up in 1718 got an
awful lot better and he's going in the
wrong direction again so I wondered you
know what is driving this we no longer
transitioning between buildings or
anything so perhaps one wouldn't expect
it and the same thing if you look down
at the hero3 average number of days
sickness has gone from 1.6 - which is
reasonable at all - 4 point 6 3 which is
again heading heavily in the wrong
direction so I wonder what sort of issue
with God what's this pointing us to
[Applause]
thank you guys that if I can take you
and appreciate you a little you're
looking at the spreadsheet as it were
but if I take you to page 4 which came
with the supplementary papers there's a
bit more commentary there so HR 2 and HR
3 of the two that you're looking at so
you'll see there that the long term
sickness relates to 14 employees at that
point in time and that that level has
remained fairly static but the number
the people themselves haven't remained
static if you see what I mean and so
there's a turnover in terms of who is on
long term at any point in time nine of
those in arts director asked your
question nine of those relate to mental
health concerns specifically which is
you
expect by the very nature or not the
things that can be quickly be resolved
that nor they things necessarily that
quickly happen in terms of them
occurring in the first place but
positively and I say this positively as
a as a manager rather than positively
and as a human being were positively
only two of those relate to work-related
absence there's still nine people who
are suffering from mental health we will
support through that process but the
reassuring thing is chief executive is
that that's not being caused in the
round by work which is which is
fantastic to see but it does mean it has
an impact on their overall workforce
it's also relatively small for 14 people
out of a workforce of over 500 is not a
significant percentage but every person
is obviously important and we want to
make sure that we're supporting them as
best possible and then HR a3 gives you a
bit more data in relation to the the
average length of sickness which as you
say has gone slightly the wrong way but
is overall not something to be concerned
about and taking the lead from counsel
whiteheads comments earlier it remains
to be seen what may or may not happen
over the winter in terms of other
illnesses what I'm secretly hopeful for
is that the good practice and I'll take
the opportunity to remind everyone in
terms of the 20 seconds of washing your
hands and washing your hands more
frequently that's common sense and
should have been happening anyway and
I'm sort of hopeful that actually might
see a reduction in sickness despite
growing a virus by virtue of better hand
hygiene but I won't count my chickens in
that regard we will see a time hotel
thank you very much chair I read that
slightly differently and I thought that
young I was pleased to see the
initiatives about mental health being
going through the organization I think
Katherine Nixon has been was very
instrumental getting that going and
staff I've spoken to that said the
mental health initiatives and I think
but please can we keep that up not just
think we've started a kind of initiative
looking at mental health that is ongoing
and that we just really don't take off
foot off the pedal on that one as it
were but my what three points I've got
really is I know you chair your comments
about the communities section but I
wonder if we can do some quite detailed
reporting about grants usage when when
that's being looked at and the other two
are on neighborhood plans support as our
joint local plan becomes made councillor
burn this year yes not looking so I'm
hopefully what will happen is our
neighbor all neighborhood plans will
need to be reviewed and I just want to
have we make sure we put that in as a
performance reporting in terms of how
many neighborhood plans are reviewed
following the joint local plan being
made and ensuring we've got support for
that and the other one that seems to
have slipped off a bit is we used to
have quite some issue up with legal
about the interaction in legal in the
amount of days it took for things to go
into legal and come back out again and
there doesn't seem to be any reporting
on that does that mean we don't have any
kind of issue there or it's all just
absolutely fine but I'd like to see some
especially because it's a shared service
I'd like to see some performance
reporting on that
thank you very much chair I know I know
it wasn't a question but I deal with the
first ones in terms of mental health yes
just to give the reassurance absolutely
we'll be letting up on that front if
anything we'll be going a lot further my
observation of the measures that we've
put in place are they're clearly working
they are positive things to be doing in
any event but they're also by their very
nature quite reactive so for example
mental health first aiders but its very
nature is something is happening as
something is going wrong that's
certainly my personal aspiration is that
we get even more proactive in that space
than where we are now and in terms of
your last question which is around label
services
that's time beautifully because the
monitoring officer snuck in at the back
of the room and so I'll give her time to
get nearer to a microphone and we can
pick up the other ones in the meantime I
wonder if you can comment on me question
on communities reporting but
establishing mobile oh yes country both
at the bed up we're going through our
review and we hope to bring you a paper
next month on our update what have
really got to thank you Joe I was trying
to be inconspicuous there and so it's
not something that we picked up as an
issue at the moment within the legal
services team but we are reviewing our
service plan at the moment and looking
at performance indicators so we can
build in something about that know I was
wondering whether I should try and
answer the question or the comment about
reviewing of neighborhood plans but as a
performance measure but I defer that to
Tommy if I may
yes we can untie it
councilman's thank you I've got a couple
of points if I may one is that I'm
surprised that there's no performance
reporting on void performance which I
was expecting to see it's already been
mentioned and canceled well it took my
question on the previous paper and I'd
also like to ask a question about wso
for about garden waste subscribers I
would imagine that that plateaus because
and it's all very well having a number
of people who've got a garden waste
subscriber but as a percentage of the
population are we about normal with
other similar districts because I would
expect that once it's plateaued we can't
expect to get any more so I just
wondered you know what other views on
that well we're talking about the amount
of garden waste subscriptions here and
that can be having more of them can be
both good and bad it's not a simple
matter of it's good more because on the
other hand the more people that deal can
deal with their own waste in a sensible
way that's a really good thing too so I
think it's a complex question which the
answer isn't just oh yes the more the
better
yes I realized that but I think I might
refer to officers for the direct
question you know response to your
question if there's someone here who
cannot do a little deal with that
outside this meeting and voids gap in
the way batons from the voids
I respect it's not not in here I
obviously this was an exceptional report
and the director of trajectory where
voids is or Slee continuing in the right
manda hence why over in scrutiny have
decided that it doesn't need that level
of rigor in terms of monitoring or slate
should there be a challenge or an issue
going forward then obviously I'll come
back and report that and explain what
we're doing about it
so the recommendations are that the
report be noted we've got a propose it
and a second all in favor
item item 11 is the community
infrastructure levy MCA 1955 cancelable
thank you this cabinet report follows in
the footsteps of the bid round 1 2 3
which took place in May and October 2018
and 2019 including the latest Silpat
decision on bid m14 / 80s locating
stealth and high school expansion which
members considered in January 2020 you
have a cabinet report in front of you a
business plan Appendix A and the
technical assessments for the individual
syllabus which own Appendix B the SIL
business plan also contains an update on
progress on decisions in bedrooms 1 2 &
3 and on bid em 14 - 8 from the cabinet
paper there are four bids with
recommendations all four for cabinet to
make those decisions from the local
infrastructure fund are called bid em 19
- 0 7 which is a proposal for a single
storey addition to the side of the
village all in our coal which will allow
the building to be used to his full
potential
it received planning permission
February 4th for 2018 it is a
collaborative SIL bid for 19,000 190
pounds with the remainder of the funds
being obtained from Iraq and section 106
funds the total cost of the works being
57600 it recommended from fund
allocation from a local infrastructure
from is from nineteen thousand one
hundred and ninety second bid is of
thorne 'm bid 19 - zero eight which is
for a forty four bay car park up thorn
and walks but the green surface made
from recycled plastic grass
reinforcement mats that will provide
strength for vehicles and a safer
surface for pedestrians the no dig
installation mesh allows grass to grow
through it also allows for the planting
of small native trees that's not the
maps but the bid small native trees will
allow foresight enhancement and shade
provision in summer whilst diverting
diversifying the environment and
benefiting local wildlife
supporting the national policy
pollinator strategy November 2014 and
very importantly mitigating the
increased co2 emissions from the
visitors vehicles the overall aim is to
provide the community with additional
parking during peak times that enhances
the natural environment people are
coming to visit in the first place it is
a collaborative bid for twenty seven
thousand pounds out of a project that
costs approximately thirty two thousand
three and nineteen and the
recommendation is for
to approve that bid for 27,000 pounds
subject to a legal document to certify
that the land can be used for this
purpose for 25 years which is equivalent
to a lease as the land is not in public
ownership third bid is brantford bid em
19 - 10 this bid is for six hundred and
forty five thousand six hundred pounds
thereabouts for a primary school
extension this represents essential
infrastructure within within the
infrastructure delivery plan and is
required to support commenced and
approved growth taking the school from
210 to 315 pupil places the proposal has
the benefit of planning permission and
it is anticipated that the project will
complete in August ready for term time
in September 2020 it is a collaborative
bid for as I said six hundred and forty
five pounds five hundred ninety three
pounds out of a project that costs a
total of 1.4 million with four hundred
and 1973 section one and six monies and
council borrowing of 440 to 956 the
recommendation is for cabinet to approve
this bid for six hundred and forty five
pounds five hundred and ninety three six
six hundred forty five thousand five
hundred ninety three pounds it is now
the fourth bid is Clayton which is bid M
19 - fourteen this bids for four hundred
and ninety nine thousand four hundred
twenty one pounds for a primary school
extension it represents the essential
infrastructure within the infrastructure
delivery plan and is required to support
commenced and approved growth taking the
school from 420 to 525 pupil places the
proposal has the benefit of planning
permission and the project completed in
September 2019 Suffolk County Council
has advanced reasons why this is a
unique
such that the approval of this case
would not set a precedent for seeking
cell phones as respectively the
recommendation to support this bid is
therefore regarded as an acceptable
exception to the SIL expenditure
framework it is a collaborative bird for
four hundred ninety nine thousand four
hundred twenty one pounds out of a
project that cost the total of 2.6
million with a hundred and with 1
million four hundred eighty nine
thousand eight of the five pounds 94 P
in section 106 monies and three hundred
three hundred and eighty-eight thousand
two hundred twenty two pounds
basically need funding and in
maintenance funding of sixteen thousand
nine hundred seven and so County Council
borrowing of two hundred five thousand
six hundred and forty-four pounds the
recommendation is for cabinet to approve
the bid for four hundred ninety nine
thousand four hundred twenty one so so
the amount of spend for bid round and
for the total expenditure on bid m14 -
18 which was determined January twenty
twenty four seven high school two
million four hundred and forty six
thousand five hundred seventy five
pounds
the total additional expenditure in bid
round four ring-fenced and local
infrastructure fund 1 million one
hundred ninety one thousand two hundred
four powers and the total expenditure
therefore in bedroom four including m14
- eighteens - upland is three million
six hundred thirty seven thousand seven
hundred and seventy nine pounds so the
recommendations have set out in your
report
paragraph three point one to make
decisions at a cold thorne and Branford
and Clayton and paragraph three point to
heaven sees us to note and endorse the
SIL business plan thank you
Enki kills the burn do you have a
seconder Thank You chair happy - happy -
second the recommendation of Fleming yes
I have a real comment on the soul report
on page 4 in appendix is it appendix it
it's actually page 1 1/4 of our papers
its appendix a and this is the
allocation of four thousand pounds for a
bus stop not giving him hmm I would ask
if we're sure we really want to include
this when the bus service was due to be
terminated at the end of this month and
it's now been you know reprieve to the
end of August is almost certainly going
to disappear are we really sure we want
to be investing in a bus stop that's my
I may have a come back depending on your
response
thank you in that table what we're in
astray ting there are the the
consultation responses that come back
when planning applications come in so
those are the expressed intentions in
this respect - of Suffolk County Council
to put in a bid for a bus stop we
haven't actually received that we've had
no bus stop requests in dizzily no and
there's another point I'd like to make
on the on the bus stops and that is I've
had a lot of conversations with the
County Council and with the District
Council and various stakeholders about
trying to maintain certain key bus
routes and one of the things we are
looking at it is in some instances where
so money has been allocated to a bus
stop with the parish councils approval
that money can actually be allocated
into investment in a bus service and I
would just like to put a flag down here
that in this case that would probably
what be what will be requesting because
the bus stop in a village with no bus is
is simply not on thank you when we spend
sil money we have to spend it on
infrastructure so actually supporting a
request for a bid for a bus service
would be something that would be outside
the terms of our scheme so I didn't say
a bus service okay I've been into this
maybe you can invest in things to
support hey a transport system without
investing in a service if I can come in
there well we'll await any bids that
come forward from seven County Council
and judge them on their merits as
they're received he has the gold thank
you I want to go back to the
recommendations and just a word of
endorsement in relation to the Auckland
proposal I've called that now been in
the I Ward as I think the this will be
well used this is a one view center it's
a very active that village they are well
organized the relatively small
proportion of the total fund cost been
sought through the silk flow sealed bid
tells you that I'm also grateful
personally in that this is not about too
clearly an interest i rapidly say but at
the moment parish council meetings can't
start until at least eight o'clock to
let their table tennis tables are being
cleared away because building this so
I'll use so we'll be able to start
parish council me
at a reasonable time with this guy's
head butt bit seriously this is I think
a good bid which will make a difference
to a very active village thank you any
questions councillor thank you very much
and I've got a couple if I may and I
agree with counsel feminism as well I
know the parishes that are paying for
bus services now so they've got and they
have new bus stops as well to serve them
but just on Silverstone market could
could you just confirm I know the
majority of stone market doesn't get
fill money but there's a Cedars park one
in here so that's outside of the general
stone market still - if you could just
confirm that and secondly I know that
the AV charging point in stone market
has been withdrawn pending you know
quotes and so on and so forth and I know
that that's our own made suffix
application and I just urge the council
not just to look at one because we've
been going through the motions to get an
e V charging point in them please can we
get two or three in rather than rather
than just one at this point in time
thank you very much chair yes I think
I've already indicated that any charging
points are under discussion at the
moment since we know what we've decided
you know Christina you incident and so
in respective stock market there are
some development sites which when we
brought in the sill charging schedule we
decided that those would be section 106
sites and they would be exempt from sin
and clearly going forward with the local
plan there'll be a review of what sites
are coming forward and whether sites are
strategic or sill related in respect of
the other point my mind has gone blank
just for a second oh yes we had a
meeting actually only last week thank
you for that which not only did we talk
about how
we could bring this forward but the
conversation was around how many points
and the fact that because of the the
fact that you have to take the power
line through a retaining wall which UK
power are very reluctant to do it would
probably have to go up the slope and it
would be a very costly exercise and so
therefore the conversation was around
how many points did we want to put in if
the you know the structural side of the
costs were going to be high so we
haven't got to the end of that
conversation yet but that was the nature
of of what we spoke about
councillor Brewster thank you madam
chair and yes just a hop can slowly burn
on that fact of Cedars Park it's my
understanding of that part that did get
Shilpa tickets was eligible for sale was
not part of the strategic side my
thoughts I just wanted that confirmed if
that was the that was the case thank you
yeah if I can just continue and madam
chair looking through the
recommendations I find I do have some
difficulty and that is with the final
one the Clayton primary-school m-19
stroke 14 I'm finding this very very
hard to actually put a positive vote on
as a matter of principle because of the
retrospective application and I know and
I was sorry that I couldn't get to the
meeting that you it was held with the
county and I've got other meetings and I
had to fulfill those meetings but I
would be interested firstly to know how
it's been planned that it won't ever
happen again I think we could have
embarrassment going into the future
because we've dealt with the one
retrospective site and you know it's
I do find it very difficult because I
were I would the I know it's a school
and for that reason if I had the
opportunity I would abstain from the
vote but it's included in the whole
recommendation so that puts me in a
little bit of difficulty thank you so
we've been meeting with regularly with
infrastructure providers each month so
health education for the last 18 months
so that was very shortly probably three
or four months after we brought our
silly expenditure scheme in and we've
been developing through that period a
pipeline of infrastructure provision and
expenditure in order to bring forward to
support growth which is happening so in
respect of this particular bid the
County were have explained that this is
something which they didn't bring or put
on our radar until September October
last year and I have checked our records
and that is so and that would have been
around the time that the scheme was
completed so I haven't much more to
offer in relation to that other than we
will continue to meet regularly working
dialogue is is as effective as I think
it can be at the moment and we will
strive to improve that with any changes
that we bring forward with this will
expenditure framework which will look to
involve more community engagement at the
time when SIL bids come forward I just
come back in and how will we avoid
retrospective in the future that's
what's really my problem well we
exchange information in relation to
commencements we understand what
development is coming forward and we
talk about what is necessary in order to
support that and hopefully those
conversations
are things which are happening in
advance of SIL bids coming forward we
are looking we have asked the question
of Suffolk County Council in relation to
education when the next school bids
would be being brought forward and the
answer that I've been given is that we
it's unlikely that we will need anything
until 2023 so the discussions will be
around the commencements where the
growth is happening on what is necessary
to trigger that council burden yes I do
I do understand that explanation
Christine with regard to relation
relationship with the County Council
that probably satisfies my concerns
about similar similar bids being made
after the event from the county council
but it's I shared councillor Bruce's
concerns that as a principal that also
can that the ability to apply
retrospectively can also apply to
non-count he counseled sources are there
any reassurances you can oh and the
other part of my question would be how
did the county justify the fact that
they didn't what do they have a good
reason for not coming forward with that
request before they actually did so this
to the first of that question thank you
if I can and assist here the County
Council apologized for an error on their
behalf which was they've held their
hands up and said that it was an error
on their
they're part that they didn't come
forward and make a bid for Clayton
primary school at the appropriate time
it was a misinterpretation of one of
their offices just to return to the I
think the substantive part of both of
the most recent points and just to
remind counselors the refreshed SIL
expenditure framework will be coming to
Council in April and you have an
opportunity there to reinforce the
strength of feeling that you have around
retrospective applications and if you
wanted to kind of solidify your approach
as a cabinet in terms of accepting or
not retrospective bits then you could do
that at the time of full council when
you're endorsing the refreshed and new
SIL expenditure framework
counselor field we opted to intervene in
a way but Clayton is in my County
division and of their self funding I
believe is coming from a development
team breaking him which is in my
district division my interpretation
understanding that it was a mistake on
behalf of County officer is that black
Pike development was very close to the
transition from 106 agreements to SIL
funding and he undoubtedly caused the
beside the fumbling of the of the baton
as it was passed I guess it we've
certainly my belief I was also gonna say
I was somewhat pleased to see the
development obviously Brantford again
which is a school which is absolutely
full and requires the expansion is going
to see this money funding it at this
time and both those schools are
supporting very substantial developments
in the area so if it's a plea I think
that the money is necessary
so we have a loser and a seconder can
ask for show of hands in favor of
recommendations thank you very much
everybody
item number 12 mca 1956 is the
appointment of contractor and request
for additional funding for the Needham
Lake cafe and visitor suit think about a
chairman and just as an introduction and
I thought it might be useful to name the
counselor working group that's worked on
this over ever quite a long period now
that is of course and jemmye yourself
counselor Flatman counselor fleming
myself and the two board members
councillor phillips and councillor
norris we are committed to providing a
high-quality experience at Needham Lake
and the visitor center and Cafe will
contribute to this by offering a new
venue for the community and visitors
with local and sustainable sourced food
and drink this important facility at
Needham Lake has been shaped by the
community who have been fully engaged in
the process including over a hundred
people attending the drop-in event in
October before the planning application
was submitted the design and facilities
of the building have evolved through
engagement process the original cabinet
decision in March last year and I
emphasize this madam chairman was
approved with indicative costs and
highlighted that the ground conditions
including clean water to the site and
drainage costs were risks to the project
further detailed studies and surveys
were completed and due to the natural
location and lack of services to the
side the cost of providing solutions is
higher than originally anticipated we
have ensured that the sustainable
principles outlined in the original
cabinet report have been reap applied
the sustainable elements to the
facilities are solar panels to the roof
cross lemon-aid story cross limit a
permit
laminated
and timber structure from sustainably
sourced wood products which is
constructed off-site in modular form
on-site drainage with reed bed diffusion
ground source heat pump the shape of the
building improves the thermal envelope
more carbon efficient natural
infiltration service water drainage sets
throughout the design and layout of the
facility and any changes to the scheme
have been monitored by the councillor
working group including the ward
councillors environmental sustainability
is inherent in the building design and
all the service connections plus the
future operation of the facility we are
committed to creating a building which
reflects its surroundings and services
its community and visitor base there are
two options available for the cabinet to
consider in the recommendations and I
would advise that option two is approved
to ensure that the facility that we
wanted is delivered in accordance with
our sustainability principles and
provides access for all and I'm happy to
recommend the recommendation sorry but
approve proposed the recommendations and
I look for a seconder
Thank You chair I'd just like to add
something to this cheering engaged
during engagement with the community it
was evident that a change in case
facility would enhance the center and
enable full access for all visitors
there are approximately three hundred
and eighty thousand visitors to the site
and therefore this facility is very
desirable and supported by the mid
Suffolk disability forum this was an
additional cost as it did not form part
of the original design this changing
place facility would be one of only a
handful in mid Suffolk and the first
will need a market I have to say after
we had the community engagement I had
correspondents from different parents
asking to consider a change in place
facility and one coupling
they they outlined their day it needs a
market like and they said they have they
take their disabled son and they have a
fantastic time but unfortunately they
have to leave after about an hour to go
home to change with this facility they
said that would just happe a whole day
out and they could go to the cafe and
enjoy their whole day there and with
that I also thought then that this would
appeal to many different schools that
have students with disabilities they
would be able to use the facility for
science for nature products projects and
this would enable them to have a really
lovely enter turn trip or you know
midterm trip and enhance the lives of
those children Thank You chair and I'm
very happy to support the recommendation
do we have any questions thank you
sometime within the last seven days on
the internet and read an article and
unfortunately despite my best endeavours
that note should refine this article but
the gist of this article as I read it
was saying that the government were
looking to change their policy in regard
to gender neutral toilets insofar as all
public buildings should have separate
facilities rather than combined
facilities and my only concern is that
if this is correct as I read it and you
know we're literally building this out
over the next few months that it would
be ashamed to then build it and then
find it's not compliant and have to make
alterations so I just like offices if
they could to either informally or
formally just make sure that I what I
read I didn't dream about and it was it
is correct I'm too sure
the building has built will be long-term
compliant you know I I'm not entirely
sure what you've read so I don't know
that I've read what you've read and but
we are following current guidelines and
at this moment in time that's that's
what we have to do so at the moment we
are we've designed the building to have
unisex toilets and just say we're
following current guidelines yes my only
concern was as again as I read it it
seemed like it was fairly imminent
change in government policy as opposed
to somewhere down the line so that's why
I flag you keep an eye on it anybody
else have any questions I have a
proposal and a seconder can have a show
of hands in favor of the recommendations
thank you
so the the date of the next meeting is
the sixth of April at 2:30 or to seeing
you
meeting closed